Let's just talk about toxicity in general.
Toxicity can block any of these pathways.
So I could have a perfectly open pathway, meaning I have no genetic defects, but I have
a toxicity that blocks that pathway.
This is one of the theories, actually, with why there's such a high incidence of autism
in the United States versus other countries that it's been researched that use the same
vaccine schedule.
Here it was one of the conclusive differences.
In the United States, doctors are taught that you should go home and give your child
tylidol so that they don't have any ill effects of the vaccine.
Tylidol blocks the MTHFR pathway.
So if I have a double and only own defective MTHFR C6777, I already have a 65% average reduction
of that function or that gene, and then you give tylidol to a kid's toast, other countries
that don't have the same autism rate don't suggest tylidol.
So this is where I've got do vaccines cause autism?
No.
The toxicity causes autism.
You have those defects and you have other compromised things.
You're going to have blood, you're going to have brain issues because of that.
So if you have to choose a paid medication and if you don't have that one ABP-1 gene that
detoxes insads and that's clear, tylidol is not your best choice any how.
Matter of fact, there's another friend that I have Dr. Susie Cohen in California who's a
functional pharmacologist who are a really nice book of the genes, oh she didn't write
a book.
But she wrote a book on the pharmacology and it's function of the body and the ill effects
of it and she has a really nice chart system on how different pharmaceuticals block different
pathways.
So this is another reason why I may say I'm not going to take a patient.
So person's on multiple medications, it's like this is going to be a really difficult
case.
So you're blocking so many pathways with those medications.
Your own benzodiazepines, it's going to be a very difficult case.
So the least amount of medications you can be on, the better off you're going to be.
Yep, I think she's done a wonderful job.
When her book Dr. Susie Cohen's book be helpful for a practitioner especially I think it's
really important.
So these are all different genes in this pathway and I'm going to go through them.